it's been 16 years since a little film
called Grindhouse first appeared that
featured a slew of fake trailers like
hobo with a shotgun ELO with a shotgun
he's pissed me the goddamn P fresh of
the success of a little film called
hostile director Eli Roth was asked by
Quinton Tarantino and Robert Rodriguez
to direct the horror trailer
Thanksgiving fast forward to today and a
featurelength version has graced us this
holiday season with with tons of fun
callbacks and some truly gruesome kills
so in this video we're going to break it
all down highlight some of these
differences and see if you can guess the
identity of the killer now make sure to
like And subscribe or else at
Thanksgiving dinner you might get
confronted by your Politically Incorrect
Uncle I said it before and I'll say it
again gay guys are still funnier than
women welcome to Plymouth Massachusetts
an app setting for a movie called
Thanksgiving since that's where the
first Thanksgiving took place over 400
years ago the setup for the film takes
place here at w Mark where the promise
of Black Friday sales has amassed a mob
of bloodthirsty consumers on the hunt
for the biggest deals but the event
turns deadly as the mob stampedes past
the doors trampling customers and
killing countless others causing Sheriff
Eric Nan to fire a warning shot as the
film fast forwards an entire year the
aftermath of the right Mark tragedy saw
Zero arrests and no one held accountable
but little do the town's folk of
Plymouth know is that someone has been
biting their time hellbent on Revenge
for what happened this is the ruthless
killer known as John Carver we get a
brief glimpse of his layer in the
Grindhouse trailer the Killer is simply
known as the pilgrim but the movie has
fleshed this character out making him
synonymous with the real life John
Carver who became the first governor of
the Plymouth Colony we can see newspaper
clippings of the right Mark tragedy
saying Black Friday traged tragedy
yields no arrest and that the deaths
were deemed an accident so it seems
whoever this killer is has some sort of
personal Vendetta against those
responsible now the film does a pretty
good job at giving us a slew of
potential suspects there's Mitch a guy
whose wife was killed the night of the
tragedy and demands Justice Ryan our
protagonist Jessica's boyfriend who lies
to the cops about what happened that
night and Bobby Jessica's former
boyfriend who mysteriously disappears
after the right Mark tragedy the main
events of the film follow Jessica and
her friends as they're both haunted and
taunted by this elusive killer as the
daughter of w Mar's owner Thomas Wright
yes his name is literally right they
were able to get into the store ahead of
the mob with a few of them even taunting
the mob goating them towards violence
thus these kids are on John Carver's
carving list and he's made an Instagram
account laying a Thanksgiving table
which he'll soon adorn with their
corpses and it doesn't take long for the
killer to get to work killing as many
people involved in the right Mark
tragedy as possible first on the
Killer's chopping list is Lizzy a
waitress at the local Diner who pushed
and shoved her way to the front of the
line during the right Mark tragedy
she'll be dunked in water and face
Frozen to the diner's freezer door
before her body is cut in half and
there's something terribly ironic about
her torso festooned above right Mart and
a sign that reads 50% off the second is
the coward security guard who ran away
the night of the tragedy instead of
doing his job and keeping order he'll
have his head decapitated now one of the
most iconic scenes from the original
trailer is the cheerleader scene where a
jock is treated to a nice little show by
one of the cheerleaders I'm giving
thanks this made it into the movie where
the killer completely twists the neck of
the jock who is one of the main
instigators in riling up the crowd
during the r Mark tragedy his
cheerleader friend is also stabbed to
death while trampolining Julia one of
Jess's friends has her life cut short
when John Carver stabs her ears with
corn on the cob holders it's a bit
ironic since these things are supposed
to go in ears of corn but now they're
literally being stabbed into ears her
house is actually undergoing Renovations
which provides the perfect opportunity
for her guts to be rearranged by a
nearby power saw one of the main
features of the original Thanksgiving
trailer was the Thanksgiving Day Parade
where a turkey mascot gets decapitated
in broad daylight by the pilgrim this
also happens in the feature but with a
Twist the Killer is smart and knows the
police are looking for someone dressed
as John Carver in fact they intend to
use the parade to trap the killer but
little do they know he's ditched the
Carver costume for now and dresses as a
clown littering the street in smoke
bombs allowing him to incapacitate his
remaining victims and prepare them for
the feast one such victim is Kathleen
Jess's stepmom who was complicit in
deleting the security camera footage the
night of the right Mark tragedy we'll
see the killer dicing up some veggies
and readying the cranberry sauce as
Kathleen's body is prepared just like a
turkey similar to the Grindhouse trailer
where the family has to eat one of their
loved ones she manages to escape this
basement and runs upstairs to find the
barely alive cheerleader chilling in the
fridge before she's recaptured and
cooked alive in an industrial oven now
the killer has all his victims some
alive some dead ready for the
Thanksgiving feast but killing them
isn't enough he wants to broadcast it
live for all to see so that every
Thanksgiving going forward people will
remember what they have done the killer
will even carve off a piece of cooked
Kathleen wanting her husband to eat her
but before that happens Jessica manages
to break free from her restraints and
make a run for it with Carver in Hot
Pursuit Jessica emerges from Carver's
Lair which we now see is located
underneath John Carver's original
Pilgrim home she makes her way to the
nearby abandoned Factory where the
parade floats have been stored to find
an unconscious Sheriff nulan knocked out
by the Killer she grabs his gun and
flees inside only to make the shocking
discovery that the Killer's identity is
her ex-boyfriend Bobby or is it luckily
the sheriff appears and manages to scare
off Bobby Bobby had left behind his
phone which was logged into the John
Carver Instagram account the same one
that broadcasted the feast but just
notices something odd about the sheriff
his boots they're the same ones the
killer wore and they're covered in Burrs
burs which littered the forest near
Carver's home when she escaped Bobby
isn't the killer it's the sheriff in
fact we'll learn that the sheriff had
planned to pin all these murders on
Bobby he had Bobby drugged put him in
the John Carver costume and rigged his
phone with the John Carver account the
plan was supposed to go off without a
hitch if it weren't for Jessica and
Bobby escaping Bobby Hit the sheriff
with a tire iron after he was drugged
and put into the sheriff's trunk that's
why Jess saw the sheriff unconscious
with Bobby fleeing from the scene but
why would the sheriff go through all
this effort to kill all these people
what's his motivation turns out he was
having an affair with Mitch's wife
Amanda a woman who met a tragic end at w
Mar when a shopping cart smashed into
her head Mitch and Amanda had plans to
run off together after Thanksgiving but
with her dead Sheriff Nan's future life
with her was dashed he therefore saw
those involved as complicit in her death
and wanted to enact revenge on those who
put greed above the well-being of others
thankfully Bobby hasn't run off too far
and his there to save Jess as the two
make a run for his tow truck as they
flee Jess turns on a gas-powered
inflatable turkey to block the sheriff's
Pursuit unfortunately it's not enough as
the sheriff ties the truck's toe cable
around a pillar and stops their escape
he's about to finish the both of them
when Jess fires this prop musket at that
inflatable turkey which had been slowly
filling up with flammable gas the place
Goes Up in Flames as Jess and Bobby
narrowly Escape but when the fire
department comes they say say that the
heat was so intense no body could be
found all that was left was Ash so it
begs the question did the sheriff go up
in Flames leaving the terror of John
Carver behind them or is he still on the
loose the film leaves us with one final
jump scare an unknown amount of days
after the final scene Jess goes into her
closet and is attacked by a flaming John
Carver it's just a dream but shows us
that even if John Carver is gone he'll
continue to haunt her till she dies but
now I turn it over to you what did you
think of Thanksgiving I want to hear
your thoughts and theories in the
comments below thanks for watching be
sure to like And subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on Twitter
and Instagram at thinkstory YT until
next time remember Daddy loves you very
much